Before looking at how that works, I want to demonstrate
what happens when we connect using TLS in the browser.
Different browsers deal with TLS in different ways.
If we connect to https://www.google.com that's using SSL to connect,
we can see in the address bar it's indicating that it's a secured connection.
If we click on that, we can see more information about that.
We are connected to the site google.com, unknown who it's run by,
and it is verified by a certificate provided by Thawte Consulting Ltd,
and we can click on this to get more information about that key.
This has the information about the certificate, and we can click on the certificate to see what it was.
It says our communication between the sites is now being encrypted.
As the result of the Handshake Protocol, the client and the server have agreed on the key,
and now all the messages between our client and the server are encrypted using that key.
If we look at the certificate, we'll see more information
about how that was established, and we have an SSL server certificate.
It indicates who it was issued to, so it was issued to www.google.com.
That matches the name of the site we connected to,
and it explains who issued the certificate, and it has fingerprints for the certificate.
We can also see that it has an expiration date.
Certificates don't last forever. That's an important property.
If the certificate lasted forever, we'd have to have a very strong encryption on it.
By making it expire, the key license needed for the certificate
can be predicted based on expected computing power until the expiration time.
We can see more if we look in the details.
This is where we get into the real issue of how the certificates work--
that there is a chain of authorities that validate the certificate.
We'll talk about that more soon and then look at this again.